performing for the hospital staff that
helped 13 year old Marcus Brown recover
from RSV this respiratory virus has been
plaguing hospitals all across the
country with children being mostly
impacted but today a grand performance
was his way of showing his appreciation
to the hospital staff that treated him
Victoria Saha was at UMC for the special
day
I won't wake up
music is 13 year old Marcus Brown's
passion he didn't speak to Lewis four so
he spoke through music born three months
early Marcus has had many Health
complications growing up what
which is why when he contracted RSV it
was scary we brought him into Quick Care
and in 10 minutes we were on our way
here Marcus was in the UMC pediatric ICU
for six days coughing
and a
breathing right because they were
putting heavily back
he got worse before he got better the
hospital stopped say it was their
musical Therapy Program that would bring
a smile to Marcus's face while he went
through treatment I was like scared
because I missed being home and I met
that and I missed my uh
um brother but Marcus pulled through
from being an oxygen 24 7.
to performing in front of a crowd at UMC
just Weeks Later
it was his way to say thank you the best
way he knew how Okay
eight news now